- It's a smoke detector.
- Right, but it's rebranded
as a musical instrument.
- And, of course, you're doing
that for what reason, to--
- To avoid the tariffs.
-  After telling Judge Filosa
my plan,
he read over the tariff laws
and told me that my work
was far from done.
that this particular thing
is accepted
by the general public
as a musical instrument.
- Okay.
- This label proves nothing.
- So how would you make
it accepted by the public?
- If it's used in a song
that people really recognize,
it's a #1 record, or, you know,
one of these singers--
- I knew that rebranding
a smoke detector would be tough
but I never thought I'd have
to create a hit song
using one of the worst noises
imaginable.
[shrill tone]
And if I was going to do this,
I'd need some
serious musical talent.
So I put up some fliers
announcing open
auditions for a new band.
And later that week, posing
as a big-time record producer,
I opened my doors
to the best of what L.A.
had to offer.
All right,
let's see what you got, my man.
- Sure.
[clears throat]
♪ Don't look at the clock,
it's deceiving ♪
♪ Everything you are so
dependent on perceiving ♪
♪ The future, fickle
notions of your mind ♪
♪ Dust, creatures of the surf ♪
♪ Always contemplating time
to a saddening extreme ♪
♪ Many of us travel,
sheep without shepherds ♪
♪ And unprepared
for battle to unravel...♪
-  The turnout was better
than I expected,
and it was clear right away
I was drowning in talent.
- ♪ Arise, the time is now ♪
- So after auditioning
a drummer named Chris
who could really
pound the skins
and Jani,
a physically attractive singer,
who had the right
kind of ambition--
- I mean,
on a wider perspective, like,
I want the whole world
to hear what I have to say.
-  My band
was starting to take shape.
- This is freedom to me.
-  But I still needed
to figure out which musician
was best suited
to playing the smoke detector.
So I organized the band's
first rehearsal,
and after watching them jam...
[tuneless jamming]
♪ ♪
- It quickly became clear
the standout talent was Eddie.
- [playing rapid riffs]
- He was not only
the best musician
but also the best showman.
If anyone could make the smoke
detector work, it was him.
So after rehearsal was over,
I kept Eddie behind
to show him his new instrument.
-  I can sing,
I can play the drums.
This is not an instrument.
- It is.
It's a blues smoke detector.
[smoke alarm sounds]
- No, no.
- This is gonna be the thing
that separates us
from any other band.
- [laughs]
Okay.
- And that means the guy
who plays it
is going to be
the most famous.
You want to be famous,
don't you?
- Um...
maybe.
- You do.
- Yeah.
-  Dazzled by the promise
of fame,
Eddie agreed to learn
the blues smoke detector
with the help
of our instructional DVD.
- The best way to play it
is simply by pressing
the "test" button on the front.
- [smoke alarm sounds]
- Okay.
[smoke alarm sounds]
-  So with Eddie on board,
I spent the next couple days
writing lyrics for
what would hopefully be
our breakthrough single.
And then I called the band
back together
to see what they thought.
So you know when you
really like a girl,
but she won't even
look at you in the eye?
You know?
- Mm-hmm.
- This song's, uh,
kind of about that.
[exhales]
Sorry, I'm just a little
nervous right now,
because it's, you know,
it's personal,
and I'm not the best singer.
But...
[clears throat]
♪ When I talk to other
people about you ♪
♪ I say "her" ♪
♪ In my bed rests a pillow ♪
♪ Where you once were ♪
♪ My lips, my hair, my skin,
my eyes ♪
♪ When you left me,
it was a big surprise ♪
♪ Maybe one day
I'll wake up on Jupiter ♪
♪ An entire planet,
just me and her ♪
- The band seemed to
like my song...
Thank you.
But then Jani said
that he had a song of his own
that he'd been working on.
-  Through distancing ourselves
from nature,
we've distanced
ourselves from each other,
and the song's
kind of based off that.
- I like that message.
- I mean, we need to respect
like the habitat we live in.
♪ It's time to revolutionize ♪
♪ It's time
to revolutionize ♪
♪ We're bringing on
on those orphaned skies ♪
- The song was called
"Orphaned Skies,"
and after taking a band vote,
they liked his song more.
And that was great,
because the best song won,
and that's what we wanted.
So I told Jani to teach it
to the rest of the band,
with one minor adjustment.
- Just so you guys know,
I took Eddie off guitar,
and he's going to be
on smoke detector for this one.
- Smoke detector?
- I know it's a bit weird,
but it's really important this
band has a smoke detector in it.
I think it could be the thing
that maybe makes us stand out.
- Do we have to have that one?
- The smoke detector?
- Yes.
- I mean, no offense,
but if you guys are good enough,
you should be able
to make it work, right?
[singing indistinctly]
[smoke detector beeps]
♪ ♪
[beep]